that's right fresh after I got that
Justice League trailer video of
ourselves a new trailer for Thor
Ragnarok behind me and I don't in a
trailer for Thor Ragnarok it ultimately
recaps what we knew from the last
trailer doors talking to Hulk and he's
like hella pretty much wrecked my home
lost my hammer that happened yesterday
it's still pretty fresh and it's all
vibe in this trailer is that yep it's a
buddy movie a buddy comedy a buddy
action comedy they really shines with a
dialogue between Thor and the Hulk where
we saw from the last trailer the two are
going to meet they're going to fight
other question I was left with is like
is it going to be the Incredible Hulk
the entire time turned out no Thor Bruce
Banner they have dialogue together stars
like we're putting a team together I'm
like aren't we all this trailer has some
great imagery though man some of the
imagery in this trailer I was like
that's from a painting or at the very
least a magic card for magic together
which also makes for great paintings but
this really does have whimsy to it so I
like this phase like where we're at in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so like I
got it at those boring a lot of damage a
lot of world ending events and a lot of
people coming together a lot of people
saving some civilizations so you have to
have different tone different vibe to it
it sounds damn entertaining Jersey's
Thor and banner or Thor in the Hulk in a
buddy movie a movie that looks like it
has a lot of fun and damage but gets
[ __ ] real and it needs to if Fenrir
is in it not gray back from Harry Potter
talking Norse mythology wolf so if I
could team up with Loki and then getting
their team together
Loki started out in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as a villain for sure I was
more or less an antihero Benedict he's
an [ __ ] he's mischievous that's not
to say they don't have common goals in
this situation he is chained up after
all there is something weird oh I don't
want to say sacrilegious just weird
hissing Thor use a gun laser gun Raygun
whatever kind of gun it absolutely fits
in the world that is this trailer for
dudes using the gun it's like eating
cereal with a spork doable - strange
love it when you use lightning mouth
because that's really the first time
I've seen that's usually like a
millionnaire and the Lightning goes into
the hammer this is straight-up mortal
kombat style there that is a raiding
moment right there
thanks dawned on me his eyes have never
glowed like Rhett he's never had the
Raiden moment all these movies no
raiding moment I could practically hear
the full callback it's pretty cool so
I'm using that image as part of my son
man
they I've never seen the Hulk talk as
much in a movie as I have in here at the
end he sort of has dialogue with Thor it
was like they were like hey Drax the
destroyer was great
let's make Hulk sound like him but makes
super Drax doesn't matter you know what
that looks like a magic card ah guys in
the end of thor ragnarok trailer from
Comic Con pretty kick-ass gave me some
fun it gave me some humor showed me the
stakes gave me some great visual imagery
showed us ultimately a buddy movie
between Thor and the Hulk or Thor and
Banner in the end another great addition
of a pretty solid Saturday of comic-con
question is Marvel DC all the trailers
who is one comic-con go read cancer all
of us enjoying the nerd boner friends I
know I am alright guys so the thor
ragnarok trailer from San Diego
comic-con have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]